Our brief today for this panel is to explore
the ways in which artificial intelligence
can work for us.
Augmented intelligence is the phrase, and
it's the benevolent face of artificial intelligence.
But let's step back for a moment for a little
bit of history.
John J.C. Licklider was a Harvard trained
psychologist at MIT teacher and he was the
first head of the technology office, at the
advanced research projects agency.
He funded some of the basic research behind
the personal computer and what became the
Internet.
And in 1960 he wrote a classic essay man,
computer symbiosis.
And in it he said that the appropriate role
for computing was to augment same word, a
human knowledge and intelligence rather than
supplanted.
And so for decades we've been debating this
issue back and forth, always in a new context.
And it is, the theme seems familiar.
The context today seems drastically different
and that's what our panel is going to explore
today.
Our first guest is an IBM fellow and manager
of Multimedia Division at IBM Watson Research
Center.
He reads IBM's research and development on
visual comprehension, including its use in
IBM Watson.
Please welcome John R Smith.
Next is the Arthur Zitrin professor of bioethics
and the director of the Center for bioethics
at New York University.
He is also the author of current controversies
in bioethics and is the editor in chief for
the Journal of moral philosophy.
Please welcome Matthew Liao.
Our next panelist is vice president for products
and strategy for integrating AI, a Toronto
based startup.
Her company uses artificial intelligence to
help businesses improve and transform customer
experiences to make those experiences more
natural, more human like.
Please welcome Kathryn Hume
Also joining us is a professor at the NYU
Stern School of business and it's center for
data science.
He is editor in chief of the journal big data
and he is also the founder of set capital
management tools.
Machine learning software is used to make
automated trading decisions in the financial
markets.
Please welcome Vasant Dar.
So John, we'll start with you.
Give us your take on artificial intelligence
and you what, what is different now and where
is it, where are we, where is it headed?
And give us a few examples from the work that
IBM is doing currently since you guys have
been doing this for decades to it.
However it's been defined over the years.
Sure, so I'm a research scientist at the IBM
and by training, you know, I'm an expert in
computer vision and at IBM, what this has
meant is I'm teaching Watson to see.
But let me take a step back a little bit from
that, there was a seminal moment more recently,
in AI and in 2011 where IBM built a computer
system in a lot of ways right at the cusp
of this second push in AI that was able to
participate on Jeopardy.
Not only was it able to compete against humans,
it was able to defeat the world champions
at Jeopardy.
So this really opened the minds of a lot of
researchers and of course a lot of work has
continued since then.
And I think we're finding ourselves in a period
of AI where, again, it seems like amazing
things are possible.
Since then, since 2011 of course, you know,
with Jeopardy all of the questions, we're
basically dealing with language.
So there were no images on Jeopardy.
However, since then the challenges around
computer vision where I, where I do work around
language translation, around speech recognition,
you know, many perceptual tasks, AI has been
able to make really great, great advances.
And I think it's put us in a position now
where we can think of many different industries
and how we can take these capabilities, which
you know, are now doing amazing things and
combine them together with human expertise
to make really significant impact.
Kathryn, you've written a bit about this,
but what, what do you think is the biggest
misperception about artificial intelligence?
Oh God, I think there's all sorts of misperceptions
that are out there.
It makes headlines to talk about the end of
work and in and announced panel, we're talking
about augmented intelligence versus the machine
suddenly replacing us all and we can all just
sit around for the rest of our lives and play
video games and smoke pot and try to figure
out what to do with ourselves, so I think
that's a misperception.
I think, my perception, my perspective here
is coming from doing a lot of work with large
enterprises who are in the process of trying
to adopt and make real applications from a
lot of the theoretical research coming out
of academic research units and things like
computer vision.
So using computers and showing them pictures
of a puppy or pictures of a glass of wine
and without any associated metadata they can,
they can recognize that and they can accurately
label those tasks.
So in doing this work with enterprises, I've
seen that this is just a lot harder than one
would think.
It's not like you can as in the Matrix, right?
If anybody's seen the Matrix where Keanu reeves
puts little chip in his brain and the next
thing you know he can.
He's an expert karate master right?
We have this impression when we think about
augmented intelligence that the systems will
get so smart that we can put our little chips
in and then we're, we'll be fluent in German
after one day of work as opposed to passing
the Malcolm Gladwell 10,000 hours in order
to learn some new skill.
But in practice it does take time and it often
takes an articulated, artfully articulated
collaboration between men and machine in order
to get going with systems.
When I'm working with large Wall Street banks
or insurance companies or media companies,
often I'll meet with sort of an executive
layer and the impression that they have is
that they can go from absolutely manual processes
to complete Netflix like automation in three
or four months.
And they ask us to scope out projects like
this where they can just plug in a machine
and, you know, we're sort of ready to go,
and what I like about Stitch Fix, and I'll
use this as a metaphor to help them understand
what this might really look like…
Does everyone know what it is?
I'll explain it, so this is a, it's an e-commerce
shopping personal shopping site.
So you go in and, say you're a woman and you're
sick and tired of shopping so you can sign
up for an account and they ask you to fill
out a form that tells you some data about
yourself.
So you know, your height, your weight, your
size, some of your taste in clothing.
So you can go on Pinterest and pick out examples
of, of images, of clothing that you might
like and you send this off into the ether.
And the next thing you know, a month later
they get a little box that has five items
of clothing that the Stitch Fix assumes and
predicts might be, might be something that
you'd like.
So this is partially algorithmic, right?
So the first past that Stitch Fix does is
to put this into some big algorithmic recommender
system where it parses the features that you've
input and then outputs recommended items,
but then they pass it to a set of personal
stylists who are just 1099 workers who go
through and they curate a selection that that
will likely be of interest to the final and
end consumer of the service.
So basically they've artfully combined human
intelligence to give feedback to those algorithms.
And then all of the data oriented algorithmic
work, and I liked this as a metaphor or I
mean literal business model as well as a metaphor
for enterprises that are trying to get started
with these tools.
Because if we take an example of say automating
a sales process in a large bank, there's a
lot of know how and knowledge and subject
matter expertise trapped within the heads
of the current employees.
And the task here is to tease out some of
those insights and transform them into statistical
patterns and systems so that there can be
this give and take and always with a feedback
loop to eventually five years down the line,
maybe get to the point where the scales tip
to the system's doing more of the work than
the people, but certainly not over overnight.
So, the big misperception here I think is
the sort of inflated hyperbole around the
fact that the machines are getting so smart,
they're gonna take over jobs tomorrow.
Vassant, why don't you pick up on that, since
you’re in a domain it is, you know, quant
hedge fund, if you will,
Sure.
So the way I sort of look at the financial
landscape is in terms of sort of high frequency
trading where the machines out at the end
of the day just very short term decisions
on one extreme and on the other hand you have
a long term decision making a la Warren Buffet
style where you're looking at factors that
you know, the machine really has no basis
for picking up on and that's a very human
The management team
Yes.
And it's just much more qualitative and there's
not enough data, right?
So it really boils down to does the machine
have enough data?
And then the middle you have sort of short
term trading where you might hold for days
a weeks.
So in the on the left hand side and the high
frequency side, there's lots of examples,
lots of repeated instances, and you can learn
the machine has a basis for learning and that
game was over a long time ago.
Machines took that over from humans.
On the right hand side you have machines that
really don't have a basis for making a decision.
So that's an inherently human endeavor, not
that humans do particularly well at it.
In fact, most humans actually underperformed
the market, you know, Warren Buffet and a
few others being notable exceptions.
And in the middle you have sort of this intermediate
space where you have enough data and the machine
has a basis to learn and trade on its own.
My experience is that humans really aren't
capable of making too many decisions in a
day, right?
If you actually have enough data, then models
of men tend to be better than man, right?
That's what the research generally tends to
show, you know, human emotions kind of get
in the way.
And so, you know, when we talk about augmented
intelligence, you have to ask yourself who's
augmenting who, you know, is the machine augmenting
humans, which has been sort of the traditional
decision support model for 50 years.
And that makes a lot of sense because their
problems where you don't have enough data
for the machine to actually make the, to be
making a decision.
And so that makes a lot of sense.
On the other hand, if it's machine augmenting
a, if it's man augmenting machine, then it,
then I feel that it's sort of a matter of
time before the machine does better because
you're training it to do better and then you
should expect it to do better over time.
So sort of to put this all together, the way
I sort of look at the world is, you know,
if you can imagine sort of predictability
on the x axis and cost per error on the y
axis than problems that fall on the lower
right are very amenable to automated decision
making.
You know, you have high predictability and
low cost per error and problems to the left
are difficult to automate because there's
low predictability relative to cost per error.
Now, interestingly, driverless cars are highly
predictable until you might expect those to
be automated, but at the moment the cost of
mistakes is very high.
So they're also very high on the y axis, which
is why we're reluctant to cede control of
our transportation yet to the machine because
we're just not sure of the sort of edge cases
or when stuff goes wrong.
It could go badly wrong, so I suspect that
that will happen very gradually
And isn't there another kind of aspect here
where there are categories of decisions.
I mean so much of this technology, which we
used to call it data science, which is data
plus machine learning algorithms.
We now call AI, right?
Its principle use was increasing your odds
of making a sale, you know, predictive product
predictions, targeted advertising, that sort
of thing.
And that's fine for decisions were better
on average is great.
To me, one of my favorite data sciences woman
named Claudia Perlich and her line on this,
she works, used to work for a Watson and now
works for ad targeting firming.
And her line is that, look, this is a great
time for experimentation in marketing because
what happens if my algorithm's wrong?
It's, you know, it's somebody sees the wrong
ad.
It's not a false positive for breast cancer,
but we're moving into these categories that
things were better on you.
You're affecting individuals' lives, medical
diagnosis, hiring decisions, and lending decisions
where, you know, individual, these are high
stakes decisions for individual lives.
And that seems to me it's a different kind
of category, isn't it?
Well, so for medical diagnosis, your trust
that falls sort of somewhere in the middle,
so let's say diabetes prediction than diagnosis
falls somewhere in the middle of the spectrum
and machines do reasonably well, but they
still make lots of errors but it.
So they still made this still significant
numbers of false positives and false negatives,
which can be particularly injurious if you
sort of missed something.
And so for that reason, the way machines are
really used as sort of to make that first
cart and categorize people into various levels
of risks that humans can then pursue in a
more structured kind of fashion.
But it sort of comes down to that the cost
of errors there are still pretty high, so
you're not going to cede control of that to
the machine.
On the other hand, imagine that we now have
genomic data available, right?
The trouble with healthcare is that most healthy
people have very few points of contact with
the healthcare system.
So there isn't enough data about them.
Right.
Whereas the sick people, there's lots of data
about them, but it's usually too late to do
much about it, so you can imagine that in
the future as we get more data about people,
your physician could very well be a machine
as well, or at least the machine group play
a much larger role in advising you on your
health.
Kathryn mentioned earlier, putting chips in
brains.
Actually, this is an area of research that
Matthew's done a lot on and it talks about
brain machine interfaces, some of primitive
ones we have now.
And he explores, kind of the future of this
in terms of what you call the control problem.
I believe so.
Elaborate on that.
So I'm a philosopher and bioethicists.
So in the bioethics community, there's a talk
of human cognitive enhancement.
So one way to amplify our intelligence, so
is to sort of amplify biological intelligence
to get us to become smarter biologically speaking.
But there's another way which is to do some
sort of symbiosis where we begin to use computer
parts and smartphones kinda like that.
You might think that your smartphone, it's
kind of like an extended mind, an extension
of your mind.
But there's more now there's something called
brain machine interfaces where there's something
called transcranial stimulation.
So you sorta put something over your head.
So companies are marketing this to athletes
so that they can sort of performed better.
They can learn better, learn quicker.
And there's actually evidence that it's not
quite like the matrix style of being able
to learn a language right away.
But it turns out that you can learn things
faster, you remember things more using even
transcranial stimulation, which is actually
a very crude technology.
And there's something else called deep brain
stimulation which is much more invasive.
And so where basically you're inserting a
theme the electrode into your brain and then
it's connected to a battery pack and then
you sort of, you can adjust the, the mode,
the electrical currents, and it's said sense
of electrical current to your brain.
And about a hundred thousand people in the
world today have already a DBS and they use
it for things like Parkinson's disease, epilepsy,
etc.
Etc.
Even depression.
But the interesting about thing about DBS
right now is that it's an open loop system.
And what that means is user controlled, right?
So you kinda manipulate, you sort of adjust
the level of electricity.
But DARPA, the Defense Advanced Research Projects
Agency, for example, it's quite interested
in something called a closed loop system where
the implant itself will auto monitor your
mood, your brain, state and your emotional
state.
So say you're a soldier in the war.
And all of a sudden you started to panic,
it will send, what DARPA wants to do is sort
of send some sort of automatic electrical
signal to calm you down, for example.
Right.
Um, and so we'll automatically monitor your
emotions and then adjust them on your, on
your behalf.
And that raises all sorts of questions about
whether this is going to solve the control
problem because, well, you know, if the machine's
deciding that for you, then who's really in
control, right?
Who's really augmenting, who?
What Vassant is talking about.
What worries you about, you know, at what
level, because we're talking about cyborgs
basically, right?
The deeper philosophical question, one issue
that's going to come up is so say, so it's
going beyond augmentation towards integration,
right?
And when you have this type of integration,
one issue is that is going to be, is this
going to still be me?
Right?
So in this literature it gets a bit science
fictiony, some people talk about uploading
your mental contents, taking like copying
all your mental content and uploading it to
the cloud so you can kind of like “Her”
or you know, if you've seen the movie “Her”
and then sort of, and that's one issue.
The thing about that is that when you upload
the mental contents into the cloud, it's not
going to be you.
And here's a way to think about why it's not
So imagine that you take, you make a thousand
copies of that, right?
And just run it in thousand different locations.
Now you're supposed to be only in one location,
right?
A so it seems like if it's running a thousand
copies all that, all those copies cannot be
you.
Right?
But the integration part seems like, maybe
you can kind of preserve some sort of identity
if its more much more integrated if some sort
of.
If our carbon-based cells can interact with
an isomorphic non-carbon based cells sort
of talk to each other if we can kind of get
at that level.
So a lot of people are working on this particular
problem, right?
Getting biological cells to talk to digital
cells.
If that can happen, then we can accomplish
some form of integration and still be you.
John, let's bring this back a little back.
What is IBM working on?
Healthcare or something that's an example
of sort of augmented intelligence that you
might.
That is either in the marketplace or in the
labs, demonstrated, right?
That can be done now that you wouldn't have
thought could have been done five years ago.
So, you know, there are many really good examples.
I'll talk about one, you know, one is in healthcare.
So, you know, today, if we think about a problem,
I'm like skin cancer, actually millions of
people around the world every year are affected
by skin cancer.
And if we look at melanoma in particular,
it's actually a very deadly form of skin cancer
where in the U.S. 10,000 people die each year.
The computer can work together with the clinician,
you know, sort of addressing the fact that
people don't always make good decisions.
They have their own biases, they get tired,
there's subjectivity, you know, there's, you
know, there's a lot there.
The computer is objective and the computer,
you know, that's, you know, that's a strong
capability that it can bring to the clinician
and point things out.
So maybe, you know, maybe there's, maybe there's
something that they haven't seen before, but
the computer has an infinite capacity to,
you know, to see thousands or tens of thousands
of cases of melanoma and make connections,
you know, the clinician, you know, may, may
miss.
So It's, you know, it's really problems like
that where we look at the strengths of the
computer, you know, the ability to look at
massive amounts of data, the ability to continuously
learn, the ability to be there without any
delay, you know, the ability to sort of interject
the right moment., B really ultimately it's
augmentation and scaling that, that human
expertise, it's not replacing that doctor,
for example, in the end.
Yeah, this is the other come back and automation
is destroying jobs…
Can l just add to that because I just want
to pick up on that, so one of the reasons
there's all of this sort of excitement about
AI is that we've made a big dent in solving
perception and the reason that's profound
is because previous generations of AI required
you to curate the input into a representation
that the machine could understand and then
we'll run with that.
Right?
So game playing in the sixties and seventies
for example, you give them a representation
of the problem of the of the chess board or
the backgammon game or whatever, and then
within the precepts of that they did their
thing and did search and all of that sort
of cool stuff, and did quite well, but you
still have to tell the machine what it was
working on.
The difference now is that machines just take
input directly from the environment.
Images like vision, they can dig and see,
they can hear, they can read and that makes
a big difference because you know, you just
kind of sidestep that laborious process of
curating the inputs for the machine and then
having the machine do kind of the rest of
it, right?
Whereas now it's doing the heavy lifting right
from the get go right from the source and
sort of doing it all the way.
Now I am a little less optimistic about the
future when I think of the world that way
because one of the basic fortes of human beings
is our ability to deal with unstructured data.
A lot of the basis of human employment is
the ability to look at images, whichever way
they come, look at handwriting, whichever
the way it comes, and then do some simple
sort of logical things on top of that.
Right, and it does, and it doesn't matter.
By the way.
This is blue-collar workers or white-collar
workers.
The machines don't really care.
The only thing that matters is that sufficient
amounts of data available.
And I think this is what the excitement is
about and the and the shifts that are going
to happen.
You know, I was in Toronto airport the other
day.
I was on a United airlines flight that happened
to be a code share with Air Canada, so we
went to the kiosk, tried my passport, no go
credit card no go, global entry didn't work
and so I need a human.
So I go into a line that's full of humans.
The lines look humans and I was thinking this
is silly, right?
All you need is a machine just watching everything,
right?
Image recognition, technology is good enough
and it can just tell Air Canada how many people
didn't need, when to sort of keep things flowing
more freely and sort of sort of doing things
the old way where you know, we're a scientist
is making Poisson assumptions about arrivals
and doing this heavy duty modeling and the
stuff has gotten a broken at the end of the
day as far as I'm concerned.
So that's sort of, where a lot of the productivity
gains I feel will accrue is from this ability
to just kind of ingest the raw data and to
be able to make intelligent decisions with
it automatically it.
So that's going to have a pretty profound
impact.
Yeah, I agree with that.
Like with the so the data science community,
we call it feature engineering.
So the sort of standard practice in data science
up to the past couple of years have been to
have a human come in and curate which aspects
of a data set are going to be most highly
with the outputs that you're looking for.
So extended example I'll give is if you're,
you've got a simple model where you're trying
to predict the prices of houses in a given
jurisdiction.
You go through and you say, well is it going
to be the square footage?
Is it the location?
Is it some sort of amenity?
And you might note that it's the square footage
that seems to be the most highly correlated
what you're looking for, so you focus on that.
And in these new deep learning neural oriented
systems, we that sometimes there are so many
possible features that could be relevant to
predict what we're looking for, that we sort
of remove that part from the equation and
focus the engineer's activity on selecting
how many layers in a network might be useful
selecting, which type of architecture because
the connections can be oriented in different
ways, will be most effective in, in deriving
the output that we're looking for, which has
lead to these breakthroughs and things like
perception.
I'm on Jeopardy is a type of problem as John
mentioned earlier on is one that's a little
bit like entity extraction or sort of basic
equations, right?
So Einstein is who's the most famous scientists
of 21st century.
It says Einstein, right?
So it goes through Wikipedia and can pull
that out, which is different from truly interpretive
semantic understanding of text, which is harder
to encode and a set of steadfast rules or
humans selected features and a is leading
to some relatively significant breakthroughs
in applications like automated text summarization
where we can build systems that make our representation
of a very long piece of text as well as a
mathematical representation of each sentence
and then basically pick out those sentences
that are most closely related to the model
of the whole, which is a thing that has struggled,
has been a struggle for the research community
for a long time.
One thing though, he mentioned that I want
to disagree with his with the medical example
and considering these computer systems more
objective than humans.
I don't think machine-learning systems are
objective, in part because of the way that
they're trained.
so I'm in the, there's two sort of camps and
machine learning, supervised learning and
unsupervised learning.
So unsupervised learning is the style that
we know when, when, when we normally think
about machine learning and from a public perception,
it's the machines magical ability to discern
patterns in data.
So that exists and it's hard and it's often
used for exploratory analysis of a data set
to get a feel for clusters of information
that have something to do with one another
so that you can then build a system.
A lot of the big breakthroughs in deep learning
today, most systems are supervised, which
means they require a human to come in and
label a set of data so they give it the right
answer.
And then the learning is optimizing the pathways
so that when it sees something that it doesn't
know yet it's been trained, the model has
been trained well enough that it can make
an accurate prediction.
So that means humans are training them, which
means there's a lot of subjectivity baked
into the systems, right?
So I’ll give you example of one where this
can have ethical consequences.
So a good friend of mine just published a
post on Medium about, a set of research that
was used to detect and assume criminality
from just from someone's photo.
So these series of photos, this was done in
China have of men and you had sort of the
top row when they every had on their white
collar and they looked like nice kind people
in the bottom row are these sort of smug faces
with furrowed brows.
And you look at that and you say, imagine
that weren't a machine learning system.
It's just you as a human who's the good guy
and who's the bad guy?
And lo and behold, you kinda, you know, it's
like at first glance you have this intuition.
So, the researchers of the paper claimed isn't
this amazing!
These systems can go out and automatically
identify criminals just from their faces when
in fact, you know, basically what the AI has
done is it's revealed to us, our prejudices,
right?
Our tendencies to look at somebody and be
like, yeah, that guy's scary and that guy's
not.
And we do this every day when we're walking
down the streets, right?
So basically it is, if we view AI there as,
as a magnifying glass to illuminate our own
human biases, I think that there's a powerful
ethical discussion to have, but it means that
if the systems, we have to assume that you
have to recognize the systems actually aren't
objective because they, they're concatenating
our own human behavior.
So I think that indeed, is a risk and certainly
it's something we have to take a, you know,
a lot of care.
In that particular case, what was the ground
truth?
I think that, you know, that's what it comes
down to, you know, with a lot of this training
if you're going to be teaching the computer
than is the information that your teaching
in with correct?
And you know, in the case of skin cancer,
you know, well, what can you do?
You can have a gold standard around, you know,
the pathology reports or you know, they're
there.
Can, you can work hard to get information
that is correct as possible when you're training
the computer.
I think these are things that we have to strive
for.
I mean, I fully agree there was always this
notion and machine learning, you know, prior
to this resurgence, which was garbage in,
garbage out and I think that still applies
today with deep learning and so on.
You know, you have to take a lot of care and
how you train these systems.
Is there, you know, the next five years, is
there something you think is going to be achievable
that you see as you know, are potentially,
it's striking and I'm thinking positive here
right
So I see more and more sort of decisions getting
automated and humans will do something else.
What they do, I don't know.
Right?
Because there's a lot of talk about, well,
they won't replace us, they'll augment us.
I'm just not seeing yet what that will be.
I mean, I accept the fact that people will
do something different, right?
If they're dangerous jobs that humans have
been doing well better than machines do them
and the human operator does something else.
But I don't see exactly how that's going to
sort of liberate us to, do, you know, more
productive things as has been the case in
the past.
So I'm sort of agnostic on this whole view
of, you know, whether, you know, like previous
waves of technology, AI is no different, you
know, it'll just make us more productive.
But I fear that it'll worsen inequality that
it will actually, you know, will still require
humans, but the kinds of things that we value
about humans like empathy and all of that,
I'm not in short supply , so they're not going
to be sort of well compensated kinds of jobs.
So I worried that the balance is shifting
heavily in terms of capital, you know, as
opposed to labor.
Anyway, take a shot at the five-year thing?
One of the other reasons why AI is taking
off right now or one of the core reasons is
actually from hardware.
So graphical processing units that were historically
used for video games.
They do a good job moving electrons and basically
in these parallel matrices as opposed to just
in a straight line like in a central processing
unit.
That was great for processing images and building
video games, the popularity of video games,
and it just so happens that the architecture
is also great for the type of mathematics
that's underlying the types of systems that
Vasant was just describing.
It’s really that combined with an immense
amount of data and just faster processing
power is really led to the quantum, no pun
intended, sort of leap in the revolution recently.
And there's other types of hardware advances
that are occurring right now.
So in those, this quantum computing world
with the, you know, and we could have a session,
they just did a session on itself to describe
this, you can given, given this sort of entanglement
properties that exist at the atomic level,
you can super, super impose various states
of a bit so that it's not just the ones and
zeros that we think of in standard deterministic,
linear processing power.
But from a probabilistic perspective and machine
learning is all about statistics and probability,
you can use one operation to basically like
sample across what could be for states if
you've just got to bits and up to many, many,
many, many, many to, to the N levels of states.
Which is significant, I think for the types
of operations and the types of hierarchical
and complex patterns that we look for in machine
learning, which could lead to potentially
like even more cool perception or perception
oriented activities.
The second is most of the time today, it's
very computationally intensive to train these
algorithms.
So you make the system smart, you bake up
the smarts, lets say I'm in a very large cloud
computing architecture.
So Google and Facebook, et cetera, they're
doing most of this work today centrally, but
all of the big companies, Google, Apple, I'd
assume Facebook in some way because of Google
and Apple is, Facebook is as well.
They're spending a lot of energy right now
to push the training of the algorithms out
onto mobile devices, which means your device
will really start to know you.
It will track your data and it will be personalized
to how you write messages, what you like,
what pictures you're interested in, etc.
And the caveat here is we go, as we think
about privacy, that could be super creepy
if these large companies then get access to
all of that data.
But from what I know, they actually are making
attempts to do this right where they're using
some new, uh, privacy techniques called differential
privacy encryption techniques, homomorphic
encryption to make sure that Google never
actually gets access to this fundamental personal
data.
And if we think about edge computing, so all
of our little toasters and shower heads and
everything connected to the internet today,
all that information has to come back to a
centralized server to then make it back to
your fridge to tell you what to cook next.
But if that processing exists out on the edge,
I think it could lead to some startling new
applications.
So that's for me, that's the sort of cool,
super exciting area.
I just want to add one thing.
I think that the area of augmented reality
is very exciting, right?
So that's kind of the machine learning coming
together with some of the processing power
that Catherine was talking about.
I think that's a world that we're augmentation
will be really cool, sort of, you know, the
world seems to be heading that way because
machine learning has become good enough to
facilitate that kind of stuff.
Hardware is kind of, you know, so the algorithms,
the AGI that we're talking about, good enough,
the hardware power is there, the speed is
there.
So it sort of, that's what I would expect
to see a lot of augmentation happening.
Yeah, imagine kids taking a field trip to
the Great Barrier Reef and swimming around
presuming that we don't kill the earth but
global warming and it still exists soon, there's
another problem that we're not talking about,
but like, you know, and they could, they could
snorkel around and have their little glasses
on and have the taxonomy of the fish be identified
in real time and.
Right.
So you could like, education could be awesome
with, with augmented reality, you could take
a walk through the park and have your botany
glasses on, you know?
Yeah.
Some people actually creating sort of doing
science labs where you, sort of, use sort
of augmented reality or virtual reality where
you go in and you can kind of do sort of experiments
in virtual labs and things like that.
But just the comment on a sort of this your
question.
While I already mentioned the brain machine
interfaces and it's already been used.
I mean, so they have people, sort of like
one person sort of like people who are paralyzed
now for example, there being computer, there'll
be wired to computers and they can now or
they're training them to be able to move different
things using their mind to type, you know,
sort of things on computers, etc. etc.
There are also people implanting things into
their body so that they can use it to open
doors to, you know, pay at checkout counters
and you can see that sort of.
I mean there was this guy with an antenna
on the head, so all that, oh that's actually
been done.
And there's a lot more integration.
And again, and you know, at DARPA is really
at the forefront of a lot of these technologies
and they're trying to get people to, there's
something called the silent top program where
they're trying to get soldiers to be able
to talk to each other using their mind.
They're really, they're trying to do that
within the next five years.
That was what near mandate.
Within five years we want to close loop system
where the machine can automatically monitor
what's going on out there and be able to put
that into the user.
Right
Intelligent, autonomous nervous system, the
outside world, the augmented reality stuff
is basically Her as a guide to the outside
world
That's exactly right.
So yeah, so I think Kathryn described many
of these, what I would call technology enablers.
I think quantum has definitely, you know,
it has enormous potential IBM is so huge.
It's a huge direction for IBM and its impact
will be enormous.
I mean just in terms of computation and computation
is important.
I mean it's actually one of the primary things
that's driving our ability to learn more complex
models and more sophisticated, sophisticated
knowledge and, and so on.
But what are the areas that I'm very interested
in, is its application of AI is to creativity
and if you think about it, you know, the sort
of the spectrum of artificial intelligence.
We talked a lot about perception, the ability
to see and hear and speak and, and, and, and
so on.
Then at the middle maybe we have more about
knowledge and reasoning, but then where, where,
where's creativity?
I think creativity is even, you know, at,
at the further end of the spectrum.
And I think it's even harder to answer the
question, “what is creativity?” then it
may be to answer “what is intelligence?”
We can sort of describe a few attributes of
creativity.
But it's hard to really know what is, what
is happening and it's, it's really entirely
a human endeavor today.
So I like to think of myself as an engineer.
It's about, it's all about method, but what
creative people do, to me, it still seems
to be magic somehow.
We did a project at IBM in this last year
around horror movies.
We actually got Watson to watch hundreds of
horror movies.
So I like to think we sent it to film school.
I also like to think I went from teaching
Watson to see, to teaching Watson to feel,
because really what we were able to encode
a Watson to do around these horror movies
was, you know, not only, you know, not just
see a objects and scenes and people and transcribed
speech, but characterize the content in terms
of emotion.
So it was a scene that it sounds scary?
Did you know, did a scene look happy?
Or did know, did it look, did it look sad?
You know, something like that.
And through these algorithms we were able
to get Watson, you know, able to make a fairly
good assessment of horror movies, but also
a horror movie trailers.
We learned the patterns for making a horror
trailer.
Essentially it came down to three things.
The scenes at a horror movie, a movie trailer
are either suspenseful, scary or tender.
That's it, but you need, you need all three.
I mean, you know, the, contrast is there and
we were able to take that simple recipe, apply
it to a brand new horror movie and have Watson
do a significant part of making the trailer
for that movie.
We just needed a film editor to come in and
within one day, you know, create an entire
trailer for the movie.
So it's a good example of taking something
which is, you know, might be a three month
effort for a production team, you know, down
to, you know, computer assisted task which
happened in a day.
But I think this just scratches the surface.
I think it points to a lot of potential for
the computer to be an assistant to augment
the creative process, to do some of the mundane
work.
The computer has no problem watching every
movie that was ever made.
If it comes down to it and can extract insights
and you know, it can really be an aid to the
creative person.
Certainly in filmmaking, but it goes beyond,
certainly goes beyond making movies.
There's a cool a trend in the computer vision
world they call it style transfer.
And this was a neat; I find this a neat accidental
byproduct of the research process.
So as people were trying to hone the algorithms
to do the type of work that john mentioned,
so come vision perceptions, a computer vision
and perception.
So being able to accurately label a picture
according to its content.
To do that, they have to pass it through this
network and it twists and turns and transforms
the input image and gradually gets rid of
all the noise so that it can focus on the
general representation that can be affiliated
with a linguistic term.
Cat, dog, glass of wine is I've been using
during the, during the presentation.
So as there was a group of researchers who
noticed that that noise that got removed just
so happened to be what we call artistic style
when they put in painting.
So if you put in Van Gogh's, Starry Night
and you pass it through these algorithms,
it will pull out the Starry Nightness.
And then you can impose that on your, your
favorite selfie on your Facebook page.
Right?
So this, I think this actually there's the
art critical community has different views
on this.
Some people say is kitsch, right?
It's ridiculous that, you know, are selfies,
can become a Rembrandt.
On the flip side, it actually is a really,
it's sort of democratizes the skillset around
art.
So there's an app called Picazzo and I've
had some conversations with the CEO of the
app who said, well, the critics panned it.
He had this influx of emails from people just
like you and I who were like, oh my god, I
always wanted to paint, but I just don't have
time to learn it and now I feel like I have
this like I have this agency and I can go
and I can make a Kandinsky and I can make
a you know, and I can make my own Mondrian
or whatever, and the commercial applications
or that, you know, you can be.
I've done a lot of work in startups and we've
got no budget so we can't afford $50,000 branding
agencies.
But it's really cool when you don't have to
hire that that, you can pull up this app and
you can for five cents, make a really professional
needs, stylistic website.
So, so it's not, you know, it's not quite
creatively like we think of it, but there
is the sacrosanct newness of, of the, you
know, of genius and art gets, it forces us
to ask these big philosophical questions about
what we value in society when we see that
this happens and it also leads to this whole
from an epistemological and cognitive perspective,
it's teaching us and it's inspired some research
on the correlations between how we see and
align language with the world that we process
and then how we make art and what's and what
qualifies as style.
So I think that's just also super cool.
You know, consequences of this, of this moment.
Well, let me just ask John on the creativity
side, because you guys had done stuff with
a cooking and other things.
Where do you kind of come out on this, anybody's
doing any kind of real reporting, a research
about artificial intelligence.
I mean, you kind of come away with a credible
appreciation for what we call general human
intelligence, right?
And only 20 watts, you know, low power, you
know, it just, and it feeds into this the
AI debate I was in particularly the brain.
I mean, is it good?
Is it an inspirational metaphor or is it a
roadmap?
Computers do not work like the human brain,
you know, they are not 20 watts and you know,
and they are very fast, but they're not massively
parallel, It's a very different ability which
can have great impact, uh, certainly for data
processing and making, you know, finding patterns
and making predictions, that's really, it's
strength, but in terms of replacing that 20
watts of, of, of human ability that they bring,
um, you know, I think we have a ways to go.
Yeah.
It reminds me that famous line by, one of
the pioneers in voice recognition who worked
for IBM for Fred Jelenik is he explained it,
you know, airplanes don't flap their wings.
You can, they do it differently.
Yeah, that's right.
And I think there is some, you said, is it
a metaphor?
Yeah, certainly there's a lot there because
whatever biological systems, you know, human
cognition perception, it's the best system
we know.
So we can learn.
We can certainly learn a lot by knowing, you
know, knowing it better, you know, knowing
how it works, it doesn't necessarily mean
that's how we should build our computers.
So I just want to comment on the creativity.
I'm not sure if it's true that machines can
be more creative than we are.
Just give one example: take like AlphaGo,
right.
So, uh, when he was playing Lee Sedol, and
he made this move is like the 34th movie.
It was like a move that nobody had ever made.
Uh you might think creativity, just in terms
of being able to come up with a come up with
solutions or sort of conceptual space that
hasn't been thought of before.
Right?
And to that extent it does satisfy that criteria
of creativity came up with ideas that haven't
been thought of before and I think machines
are going to be able to do that.
They're going to be able to locate spaces
where we haven't been to before.
So, I don't know what you think about that?
I even when Kasparov played against Deep Blue
and in chess, he reached the point where he,
you know, he felt that the computer was not
playing fair, right.
Or there was really a person behind it, right?
Because of whatever move Deep Blue had made,
it just didn't seem logical to him.
Right.
So, you know, I think there is, but in the
end, what was the Deep Blue?
Deep Blue was a massive search system.
There was no intelligence there, right?
You know, in, in the way we think, you know,
about a lot of the problems in AI.
It just was a brute force search problem.
So sometimes we might ascribe some of these
qualities to it, but certainly knowing what
was behind the curtain, you wouldn't say,
you know, Deep Blue was creative.
I see.
I think we, we're talking about like two types
of creativity here.
I think what Matthew alluded to was sort of
more in the realm of reinforcement learning
are we Kathryn mentioned, supervised or unsupervised.
There's reinforcement where the reward is
delayed, right?
And so, what Deep Mind has been really masterful
that is just sort of pushing the limits in
terms of reinforcement learning, which in
simple terms boils down to, you know, you
have an evaluation function, you're here,
you can evaluate sort of what got you there,
but then what's the remaining thing to the
end of the game?
And that's kind of a recursive kind of problem
and they become really good at solving that
problem.
And so a machine may make a move and you said,
wow, that's never happened before, that's
creative.
But there's another aspect of creativity that
sort of, it seems to be outside the realm
of these kinds of algorithms, which is we
just find ways to do stuff and we gone quite
describe it, such as even dealing with each
other.
Right?
And machines are not good at dealing with
people at the moment.
Right?
That human machine interface is actually quite
poor.
They're quite stunted in that sense and a
lot of the research efforts and creativity,
I think will make a dent in that arena and
just getting machines to be more empathic
or sort of have the kinds of qualities that
we so seamlessly seem to exhibit.
On the flip side, so there's a film called
Tim’s Vermeer and I think it's fantastic.
I think it's fantastic because it, for two
reasons.
One is it actually forces us to question our
assumptions around human artistic creativity.
So this is a movie about some guy, Tim.
Uh, he was a designer at Pixar who has a theory
about the 17th century Dutch painter Vermeer
and wants to test his theory and he assumes
that Vermeer used an optic system that had
two mirrors, one that sort of just reflected
the, the world that he was trying to depict.
And then the other one that's sort of shot
that reflection down onto a canvas and then,
Tim hypothesizes that he used something like
a paint by number type system to basically
use pigment until there was a color gradient
between what was reflected in what he was
painting.
And the minute it got there he shifted on
and he just sort of goes through and in a
seemingly extraordinarily uncreative way,
it made what were the most realistic.
And I, I'm a huge fan.
I mean just tantalizing paintings from the
17th century that looked radically different
from those of his contemporaries.
So I think what I like about that is it also
forces us to.
It's this is less about machine creativity
and more about our assumptions of what qualifies
as artistic creativity.
That has a lot of ramifications also further
scientific research community.
So, you know, I believe that the myth of the
solitary genius who sits there and solves
Fermat’s last theorem, you know, is not
necessarily the way that the innovation technology
progresses.
This is very much a back to Her and artificial
general intelligence, right?
There's, there's stuff going on collectively
that we from our, trapped in our bodies.
Subjective viewpoints don't often perceive.
But if we could perceive like who knows what
might happen.
The second cool thing about that film is that
to make this happen, Tim had to reverse engineer
he thought would have been the original scene.
So to do it he has to learn about 17th century
glasswork and textiles and woodworking.
And it's kind of this engineer's paradise,
right?
Because within this one single project lies
of the world is he has to do all, you have
to learn all these things in order to solve
his problem.
So I like it as something that also forces
us to question or are inherited assumptions
of what qualifies as human creativity in the
first place, which can be often very scientific
and constraint oriented.
Are you guys are really worried about what
you're doing is, you know, gonna make the
world a rougher place for more people?
I think.
I think IBM is very clear on this.
Um, you know, we've outlined the principles
here for AI around three dimensions and we
call it a purpose.
So you know that the role is about augmentation
of you know, working together with humans
for important industry problems.
Trust that, you know, when we build these
AI systems will make it very clear how those
models were, were learned when AI is being
used, what data is behind it, you know, and
so on.
And then the, and then the third is skill.
It actually comes back to how these systems
are trained that they are, that they will
learn from the human experts, you know, that,
it is about taking all of that human expertise
and trying to make a joint computer human
capability that's even better.
That can help scale expertise, you know, can
help, solve difficult industry problems.
So I think we're very optimistic in, you know,
in the, in the potential if we follow these
three things,
Don’t feel compelled if you don't, but if
you, if you got to put a strong point of view,
I'd like to hear.
Yeah, I worry, I don't have that optimistic
prognosis on employment.
I think the worldview of a cool place, they'll,
it'll be amazing machines, augmented reality,
all kinds of stuff.
You know, my wife yesterday showed me a Groupon
coupon for data scientists.
So did you expect to see this?
I was like, no, that's really interesting.
Um, and that kind of tells you were sort of
people are focusing on, but that's, you know,
everyone can be a data scientist, and if machines
are making of these decisions better than
us, that we'll be doing something else.
I don't know what that is.
Hard to say, what it's going to do for employment,
but like I said, I worry about inequality.
Okay.
I kind of side with the economists here.
I think there's been multiple technology revolutions
historically and that jobs haven't disappeared.
And if you look through the history, I may
come from a sort of history philosophy background.
People have worried about the same things
time and time again.
We talked about it with, there's this film
and from 1957 “Desk Set” where I'm Katharine
Hepburn and Spencer Tracy screwball comedy,
absolutely fantastic.
They were all worried they're gonna lose their
jobs in the sixties.
And it didn't happen because the computer.
I also do think though that the fact that
white collar jobs, subtasks of white collar
jobs like investment banking, wiring, accounting,
doctors, etc. pushes a sensitive button in
today's contemporary society.
So there's a lot of people in the world today
who have horrible jobs, they’re jobs they
don't really want and we don't think about
them, were worried about the fancy things.
And I think it tells us, actually some people
are worried about sort of, self driving cars
and what that's gonna do the trucking industry
as well.
And obviously with the manufacturing industry.
But, I think that I, the fact that, you know,
cognitive tasks are often hyper specialized,
which is a great candidate for narrow, narrow
intelligence leads to some discomfort with
the way in which our society is currently
constructed that people are reacting to.
So I think that there is going to be some
sort of a, it's going to transform our society,
there's going to be transitioned costs, so
people are gonna lose their jobs and it's
not so easy to retrain people, you know, especially
if you're in your fifties, etc. etc. to try
to retrain, to say, oh, you can take a course
on data mining as you know, it's very hard.
Right?
And so that's going to, it's going to hurt
a lot of people and so I do think that we
need a discussion in our society about the
unique qualities that are going to result,
you know, so in the long run, maybe so just
like, when we transition from horse buggies
to cars, right, people lost jobs, etc. etc.
We need to be able to do this this time, it's
going to happen even faster.
Right?
And so we as a society need to be able to
deal with that transition and how do we help
these people?
Do we do something like universal basic income,
etc. etc.
But we do need to have that conversation.
Otherwise the inequality is going to be hugely
exacerbate it and that's going to be really
bad.
Technologists should be part of that debate
as opposed to just the public policy people
to kind of.
So we have time for some questions if there
are, I think there people with microphones.
My main concern is how we should educate the
generation, like my son who is 12, which type
of profession, how we should encourage that,
knowing that it's going to be harder in the
future?
I've written a lot about this topic in education
in this age, so I think, you know, as we've
been talking about this whole debate between
artificial general and narrow intelligence,
the, this general as a model or something
that it really is not achieved yet and there's
a lot of value in our being able to do multiple
things, right?
So not just focusing on one single thing,
but really the value of a classical liberal
art, liberal, a liberal arts education, right?
So really sort of learning not only one thing
but, but many things will be valuable in the
future.
And then the other thing, as Matthew just
mentioned, skills transfer.
So, the, most valuable skillset that one can
have today is the ability to learn, learn
new things because as the technology keeps
changing, you don't want to get stuck in a
thing where you know, you kind of have this
one skill and if you can't perform that skill
then you're out of a job.
If you can go on a MOOC right, so a massive
online open course and learn a new skill when
you're 25, when you're 30, when you're 35,
that's going to be, these are going to be
the Darwinian fits for the new economy.
And I don't know, there's no, the education
system hasn't solved this at all.
You know, there is, and I hope that the technologists
will be in dialogue with the education policymakers
to make sure that both general education as
well as skills transfer will be will be focused
on in the future.
Another Question
The thing that's really looming on the horizon
that I see as the self-driving car, I think
there's a lot of money going there and they
really want to make it happen very quickly.
One of the things I keep hearing is going
to happen within five years.
So, you know, obviously how does this, I feel
like it's going to be shoved down our throats
rather than we're going to be allowed to arrive
at some sort of organic a solution.
So where do you guys see as, how is this going
to be implemented?
So maybe I can go.
So one of the things that we haven't really
talked about is sort of how do we build ethics
into AI and that's sort of a very prominent
in the case of self-driving car.
So as a philosopher we talk about the trolley
problems.
So what happens when a trolley goes towards
five people, you know?
Well now lets deal with the self-driving car.
Imagine now the car's driving, it's an.
It could kill five people.
Oh, could kill you, right?
You could sort of turn off to the side of
the world killing you, right?
What should the car do and how should we,
how should the program or a program that into
the car and which you buy a car that will
kill you.
Right?
Even though maybe that's the right thing to
do.
Right?
And so, and who gets to decide that?
So there's a sort of, there's a who's going
to build in these sort of ethics into the
AI.
So that's sort of a huge area that hasn't
really been discussed well that people are
starting to discuss now.
My take on that has to do with sort of like
different geographical locations are a better
fit for self-driving cars.
So Singapore it would be great, right?
So self-driving cars work the best.
If it's, if we go from human to all cars,
all self drivers, all human today also driving
tomorrow because once you've got all the cars
that are talking to one another with their
sensors, it becomes a very static system.
It loses a lot of complexity.
Bangalore is the worst place for self-driving
cars because if you ever been to Bangalore,
it's like people are honking and driving all
over the place.
There's traffic lights, right?
So it would be super hard.
It goes back to the, as was saying with the
quickness with which you have to make a decision
in the level of chaos in your system.
So I do think like, this is going to be the
technology's there, you know, and it's going
to be a policy decision where certain who
knows in the States, it'll be Uber that starts
because there is aggressive as they are and
they're just going to put the fleet out and
god knows what will happen and you know, and
then they'll get sued and they'll pay it off.
And the next thing you know, everybody will
have self-driving cars.
Right?
But um, you know, I think that it'll be a
geographically specific area, there'll be
somewhere that's more of a Singaporean like
state that will probably be like at the early
adopter, and then it'll gradually shift to,
I can't imagine when it'll make it this place
like India just because of the, but I think
the, so the, so the sort of that.
But the interesting point is going to be this,
this middle threshold where, you know, you've
got some human drivers and some self driving
cars and you've got these, I can't remember
what they call it, but it's sort of, there's
like four levels of self driving cars from,
you know, cruise control to full automation
and right now there's a lot of work on the
like when does the human intervene, who's
liable when the human intervenes and it goes
into the ethics and IP, right?
So it's like, is it the carmaker?
How do we do we model this like a software
liability problems.
So I think right now the issue is really one
of policy and ethics.
But there was another point earlier on that
is also relevant for self-driving cars.
We hold computers often to higher standards
and human behavior.
And in the self driving car world, there's
so many accidents per day that it's kind of
a no brainer that we should go to the autonomous
vehicle paradigm, even if there will be accidents,
there will be fewer than there are with human
drivers.
But it's so hard to get people to appreciate
that.
Right?
So for me, this is the sort of like the messy
debate in the, in the space right now.
And it's not all math.
Um, well, I think we're a little past time
here I want to thank the panelists and all
of you for coming.